Have you ever wondered what the difference is between the words "between" and "among"...
...and if you can use them interchangeably or if you need to choose one?
Well, the answer is that they are different...
...and you use them in a different way in different sentences.
As a rule of thumb, "between" is used when you're talking about two people or two things.
You use "among" if you're talking about more than two people or more than two things.
And I like to remember this by thinking of two cliches actually.
We tend to not like cliches in writing but sometimes they can be good memory devices.
One is the phrase "Just between you and me."
Well, "between" is correct here because we're talking about you and me.
We're just two people so it's just between you and me.
And that's one way that you can remember that "between" is used for two people.
On the other hand, we have a sentence like "You are among friends."
In this case, you might picture a large group of friends more than two.
And that's why we use the word "among"...
...to indicate that we're talking about a bigger group of people.
So again, if you're wondering about the difference between "between" and "among",...
...remember that "between" is used for two people,...
...and "among" is used for a larger group, more than two people.